self-driving ruber vehicles are now
driving around in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania you can actually summon
self-driving cars from your uber app on
your mobile phone pictures of the cars
have been spotted we know Google has
been testing their self-driving car
fleet for several years we've talked
about Tesla's autopilot full disclosure
I own some Tesla stock last week Ford
announced plans for its autonomous
ride-sharing service but we actually
have self-driving autopilot type cars
driving around in Pittsburgh now because
of the law you can't actually have no
driver and I use that term sort of
loosely sitting in the driver's seat
there is someone who sits there in case
something happens with the autopilot of
the vehicle but people are riding around
in uber --zz where the computer the AI
the the hard drive essentially of these
cars is driving people around and this
is very very interesting number one it's
interesting because every time I talked
about this Jason you wouldn't know about
this but for the last three years every
time I've mentioned self-driving cars I
get angry emails from people saying
David this is not going to happen this
is ridiculous there are going to be no
self-driving cars and we now have
self-driving trucks operating in a test
corridor in the west of the United
States we have the self driving uber z--
in Pittsburgh this is happening now it's
a question of when people will be used
to it I guess I'd get in one of these
self-driving ubers I'm gonna get in I'm
not afraid the real question me is when
are we getting self-driving Buber type
drones that are gonna fly me to my next
destination instead of driving scene
that I would understand people emailing
me about and saying David you know you
might want to spend a little less time
on the self-driving flying cars and and
that that I would actually hear but I
still get people telling me this is fake
this is not ever going to happen when
it's already happening
I've actually been thinking quite a bit
about the impact that this could have on
public mass transit like buses and
subways because when you consider that
buses and Subway's are only as cheap as
they are in many cities because they're
subsidized by either the state or other
agencies the real
cost of a bus or subway ride is often
quite higher than what people are paying
private industry could drastically
undercut the prices of public transit
especially once you phase out the need
for drivers because drivers are like the
most expensive aspect of public
transportation in most cases you can
really undercut public transit and I
could imagine a world in which we see
significantly worsening traffic because
we know that every full bus that becomes
people in cars has a huge impact on the
traffic that is actually one of my
concerns the AI the safety of the
driving algorithm that is absolutely
going to be figured out I've been
thinking more of the impact it could
have on public transit and it could be
quite damaging on the AI front though I
wonder if people are going to figure out
when they see these things I think I
know what it's gonna do so say if you go
to cut it off is it gonna stop every
time I feel like you're gonna be in
traffic and everyone's just gonna be you
know there's certain cars in traffic
that just get cut off cut off cut off is
this gonna gonna just is gonna keep that
two-foot zone where it can't get cut off
where is it gonna to be kind of the
driver that gets always cut off or yeah
happen there I have been thinking about
that and there's this thing called a
Pittsburgh left which is I don't know
how many people have heard about this
this is where if you imagine a cars
facing each other at a red light where
you can either go straight or turn left
typically when you just get a solid
green not a green arrow the people
turning left have to wait for an opening
from oncoming traffic there's this thing
called a Pittsburgh left where there's
sometimes an understanding where you let
the first car that's turning left go
through in order to make it so that they
don't get stuck waiting until the yellow
light and then have to shoot through
that's a very difficult thing to deal
with when it comes to programming so how
would a self-driving car deal with the
expectation from other drivers that you
might be doing a Pittsburgh left I don't
know the answer to that yeah there's too
many intangibles I think especially if
you start putting these behind big
trucks big buses etc there's gonna cause
traffic jams I mean eventually they're
gonna figure it out but there's gonna be
a window where there's going to be a lot
of lot of
sting and a lot of stress testing that's
gonna need to happen I don't disagree
with you but I that is not my long-term
concern with these self-driving cars I
know that that is going to be figured
out we'll see though what other chaos is
temporarily caused in the meantime